the ancient egyptians are far more
mysterious than most people realize
as they left us with literally zero
explanation
of any kind as to how they cut and
carved the tens of millions of stone
blocks that make up the pyramids
and the countless thousands of solid
stone statues and obelisks that have
been found throughout egypt
the reality is that all we have today
are theories and guesswork as to what
methods they may have utilized
to cut and carve these millions of
stones including bronze saws
and chisels and stone hammers
and what you're about to see is an
incredible clip that i took just last
month
while visiting the aswan quarry in egypt
which is the location site of the
world's largest solid stone
obelisk commonly referred to as the
unfinished obelisk
and we had the opportunity to physically
demonstrate this
method which is again a primary among
the primary methods that have been
considered
to be what the ancient egyptians used
even though again
the egyptians never told us that some
modern researchers went in there
and started they saw these stone hammers
and they're like that must be what they
have used to do it
but apparently these dorks never tried
it themselves and hey
i'm a dork no disrespect but it's not
until you actually see
what this these methods with your own
eyes that you see just how
honestly silly these methods are so look
at this clip
think for yourself and let me know what
you think here we go
hold on all right dolores stonehammers
is how they say they did it let's see
what it does on rose granite
maybe if i pour some water does that
hurt your hands how hard is that
it kind of sucks it doesn't really hurt
yet it's not
doing anything try doing a little
grinding dust
oh this is a good shot you just chop it
up dust now he is
yet starting to suck because it's really
starting to suck it hurts
this is literally the mainstream
explanation
for how this entire quarry was
accomplished
including this 1200 ton
140 foot long obelisk
literally that is the explanation which
doesn't make sense especially when you
look at all the scoop marks
which looks more indicative and i'm not
suggesting but it looks more indicative
of
sandblasting i've heard other people
stonemason say that
but how they did it is a mystery it's
yet to be demonstrated
for people using these dolorite stone
hammers
to do something like this especially
with the nature of the corners and
the scoop marks underneath and
throughout it's just silly honestly it
is a
silly explanation i'm not suggesting
they had power tools
i don't know how they did it but what i
do know is that the
so-called mainstream explanation is
debunked as far as i'm concerned when it
comes to these stone hammers and just
look at how small people are compared to
this thing
you can still hear them doing that what
do you think ben
clearly clearly stone pounders we were
wrong let's just get over it
let's get a few guys around it there's
plenty of room for like enough guys to
lift this up right
oh yeah once they're done yeah it's easy
lift it up
ropes and pillies bruh get over it
everyone together now and meanwhile
they're still chopping up dust over
there
they all got arthritis you guys will
feel that for the rest of your lives
[Laughter]
well done so this is how they claim they
did it a dolorete stone hammer
this is rose granite let me get a feel
for it
yeah it doesn't feel good on your hands
one one bit
look at that i'm doing nothing more than
kicking up dust
you know seeing just grinding it away a
little bit that is the mainstream
explanation for how this whole quarry
was quarried
yeah no i'm sorry i'm not claiming to
know how they did it
but to suggest that this whole quarry
including this 12 some 1200 ton
unfinished obelisk which is
approximately 140 feet long look at this
thing
it's deep i got pictures of me down in
there it's very tall
when you're standing at the base of the
uh of it inside the trench
it is probably nine or so feet high just
just a guess higher than my hand can
reach and i'm 5 foot 10.
yeah that is definitely not how they did
it
that's just silly yeah
nah that's that's definitely not how
they did that
clearly and do you want to hear one of
the most interesting things about that
so that stone that you saw us pounding
on
is the same exact stone that has been
pounded on for more than 20 plus years
by countless tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands
of tourists and the things barely dented
clearly that's not the method and by the
way what are those
scoop marks about that doesn't look like
i mean how there's so many of them and
they're all just no that's not
from lining up a bunch of people and
pounding away with a stone hammer
and another big question is how are they
going to lift and move that obelisk out
of that
trench once they're done with it as you
heard ben from the awesome youtube
channel uncharted x bring up
in that video clip i mean the oswa
inquiry
is the same exact quarry where the
experts say
that the stones the granite stones were
brought from to make up the pyramids and
other
places in giza five hundred plus miles
away from giza is oswan
nothing out oswan is a quarry nothing
else is there there's no statues there's
not some ceremonial place
so they were going to clearly have to
lift it take it out and bring it
somewhere else
and the reason why they didn't and which
by the way that would raise so many
questions like come on how are they
going to do that
but the reason they did is because the
thing has a crack in it and you can look
back and see that it's there and that's
the reason why they
apparently or it's believed why they had
abandoned it but not only that guys look
underneath the thing
look at those unique scoop marks how are
you going to get in there with those
stone hammers
and bang away at that it's not feasible
it holds absolutely no water and as you
just saw in the video
it's been debunked so this in itself
should be raising questions
new questions as to exploring how the
ancients were able to accomplish these
amazing
feats so anyways guys i'm going to close
it up there but i want to give a quick
shout out to
the new up-and-coming channel among the
ancient history community
which is johanna james guys we finally
have a female in the mix
and it's been long overdue she came with
ben and i on the tour
she's an actress and comedian and
screenplay writer in london
go check out her videos they're
outstanding the generating buzz already
and they're so well done
and she provides a very unique
perspective about all this ancient past
stuff but
anyways with all that said i'm jimmy my
channel is called bright insight and i
have many more videos for you to come
in a very short period of time i've been
guys i've been moving i've been busy
with all kinds of stuff if you
if you're not familiar go to my
instagram because i'm sharing a lot more
stuff on there
so if you've been wondering why i've
been sharing these other videos from my
iphone
guys those videos were not supposed to
ever go onto
youtube i was gonna put them on
instagram or just have them as jimmy's
home videos
my way of making videos is with these
presentations where i
talk and i show slides and photos and i
took tens of thousands more than 20 000
photos on this trip
so i have like enough content for dozens
and dozens of videos to come
so some people were like why did you
film in vertical because i didn't think
i was putting on the internet
anyways guys so i look forward to new
videos to come real soon
i'm uh back in arizona now i moved here
from boise idaho
uh this is where i'm originally from so
i'm really excited about that so now
that i'm settled in i
finally have time to be making more
video content so all that said
leave a comment let me know what your
thoughts are on all of this and i'll see
you all again real soon
bye now